hello guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Veronica success so I recently put
together a horror comedy called the
in-between takes with Ryan and brandy
but it should be like in between takes
from Ryan brandy Veronica and a little
bit of Jerry that's what we should say
anyway yeah so I was talking with jinx
and jinx told me that he put together a
horror short film called speak of the
devil so I was like I gotta check out
his horror short film mine's a horror
comedy I don't know if his is a comedy
at all anyway jinx let's see what your
talent is beyond more than reaction
classic heartbeat
[Music]
these names I don't know must be
[Music]
scary [ __ ] - or what job you need to
remember was Jeepers Creepers now that
was creepy add my [ __ ] Jeepers Creepers
is creepy because it was [ __ ] ugly
now you want to talk scary you gotta
talk like Michael Myers Jason mom was a
straightjacket [ __ ] we're serial killers
they real honestly I'm not scaring any
of that because serial killers you can
just kill them anyway
[Music]
it was my scare bear was totally
thinking way [ __ ] hate clowns
man that movie is scarred me for life
[Music]
[Music]
no he's got me the noise
[Music]
[Music]
miss me all the watching let's watch it
that's what you get it's not funny it
won't be for me
anything on Netflix of course we need a
bar only if you come with me okay
[Music]
how do you forget to pay the necklace
village you my youtube achoo is a bad
thing
really what look all you gotta do is
find any low-budget film and I bet it's
something besides ten minutes in we're
gonna be watching them anyway ever wrong
man blowing really most of what you want
[Music]
nice I think there was a space next to
the fridge we're deciphering you're
filming
you can't be serious you get it all
these chocolate go tickets are Willy
Wonka house I'm just an envelope around
here you can't be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I heard the camera
I heard the camera gee you [ __ ]
[Music]
about your girlfriend man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good [ __ ] jigs yeah it was fun I'm in a
conflicting situation right now hey I
feel like I really enjoyed it I really
did B I have my criticisms there's like
a certain level of criticism that I have
to be at right now because if I don't
criticize enough people are gonna say
you pussied out on criticizing jinx if I
criticized too much they're gonna say
you were way too hard and jealous of
James Dunn I have to like find this
medium here and here's what I will say
my criticisms most of them that's okay
it's totally okay it's totally okay I
still find you too attractive
most of these criticisms I think even
applied with what I currently have to
get better at - it was really
entertaining there were some fun jump
scares in there like you set out for to
make like a creepy kind of fun horror
film and I feel like you succeeded for
the most part the jump scares were good
the effect of the little girls
kind of creepy and the clown was creepy
- yeah they were all creepy this is
something that I could tell you kind of
just cooked up and you know not really a
crew it's like everyone was the crew and
cast it looks like a fun project that
you guys put together I don't know if
this is like something you're like
planning on being more like more
consistent about or more serious about
and there are some cool camera angles to
some of the cuts could just be a little
sharper I guess you would need like a
sound design guy cuz sound is so
important I feel like you would
definitely need a sound design guy I
need to get better at sound - like with
this last project we
put up I had a sound guy but I didn't
have time to give it to him so he could
do all the sound and I have to do it
myself and I'm not that great at it
so I need to get better at it to myself
I'm impressed that jinx did like all the
editing he did he wrote directed he
directed it and he added it together and
I know that since I've been watching you
doing the editing for your short film I
know that it takes a lot of time and
effort and so could I see you jinxed
impressed and kudos on your acting
skills I feel like when he wanted the
horror intention to be effective that's
where he succeeded it was more of the
stuff in-between the horror and tension
moments that I would find the criticism
there that that stuff I would try to
make more interesting stuff in-between
the horror and tension moments that I
felt could have been more captivating or
could have been more intriguing in some
way I found myself at times going like
okay I want to get back to the spooky
stuff because I'm not really getting a
big kick out of watching just these guys
hanging out I feel like if you developed
that a little bit more the character the
character dynamics and interaction
because it was like jinkx was horny for
his chick CJ so cool was horny for his
chick the dynamics were there plenty I'm
just having sex with their girlfriends I
don't know if that's like an intentional
joke is pretty funny
for your first like horror film
especially want to put up now and I know
that doing reactions and stuff it's like
you become kind of at this stage now
where we were trying to prove that we're
more than just reactors this is a big
step and like for your first one
fantastic and what's that you rapping is
that your song I think that's him
rapping at the end cool cuz we were
really getting into it yeah we were
really getting it I felt my black coming
out of me I felt like a thug like a
black thug like a gangster black thug
yeah like an ex-con seem to be
continuing convict
gangster black thought yeah yeah I
definitely got that for me I I felt it I
felt it did I feel any of that for me I
I felt like you were one of my girls
[ __ ] that I am fat pregnant
and while I'm in prison but I still want
you I'm still taking care of the baby
while my other family is you know being
attended I just hey guys if you the
challenge you get subscribe today hit
this button up here because I have to
indicate uh but I was told you should
indicate where that subscribe button is
Ryan so now I'm doing that sorry you
guys couldn't figure that out before and
you could check out Veronica's channel
where there's acoustic covers and
originals on there like I said we have
that short film up now and you could
help Veronica win a contest that is
going on right in this second so go to
make me famous dot us and vote for
Veronica six toast there's a link in the
description box round two round two is
going on right now ends tomorrow morning
so hurry up and vote for her now and
happy Halloween
I hope you have many a trick-or-treat be
safe don't get to buck while keep your
eyes open know who you're with and know
where you are and if you're anything
like jinx CJ so cool in myself you'll
know that their treats today are gonna
be blow jobs right baby you're right
baby
get your hand out of my face girl I will
stop paying child support
CJ is so cool
like who you